stephen colbert making the very same
point
russia has been hit with a series of
crippling sanctions and it looks like
there's more to come because the u.s and
its european allies are now discussing
banning imports of russian oil take that
putin we're not gonna buy our gas from a
war criminal we're gonna buy it from the
good guys saudi arabia
but
it's gonna cost
since the invasion oil prices have
skyrocketed today the average gas price
in america hit an all-time record high
of over four dollars per gallon okay
that stings but a clean conscience is
worth a buck or two
i'm willing to pay
it's important right
it's important i'm willing to pay four
dollars a gallon hell i'll pay 15
a gallon because i drive a tesla
this is such a telling joke
in every joke there is a little element
of truth and here i think there's a big
element of truth the joke is i don't
care what gas prices are you know gas
prices if they go up it just shows that
i care about freedom in ukraine that i'm
sticking it to vladimir putin i don't
care if they go up to 100 a gallon
because it doesn't affect me because i
don't even put gas in my car
yeah and so that's that's the joke
except that's the reality too there's
something else really interesting about
this clip
as a result of our ban on russian oil
america is now looking to increase oil
supplies from saudi arabia sure but also
iran and venezuela
and in the joke here colbert says oh wow
we're going from one really bad guy to
another really bad guy and the other bad
guy he points to is saudi arabia which
is actually an ally of the united states
he doesn't say oh great we're going from
russian oil to iran
because the libs love iran even though
iran is the largest state sponsor of
terror in the world the libs are super
into iran they were pushing for a
ridiculous iran deal that would have
given iran a nuclear weapon they're
pushing for that again venezuela they
love the socialist government in
venezuela they've been talking up the
socialist government in venezuela for 20
years now they've been talking it up
since the days of hugo chavez they still
like this guy nicholas maduro a
socialist dictator down there so he
won't even make that joke he won't even
make the joke oh now we've got to deal
with socialist dictators or the crazy
ayatollah and the mullahs who are
funding terror around the world no
because they like those guys too much
they only go after saudi arabia but then
he comes to his point he says look i
don't care if it's 15 a gallon because i
drive a tesla
what you're seeing here
even in this little joke
is the perversion of our system of law
from
a
care for the common good
into a care purely for self-interest
what is the law seems like a simple
question and yet i bet a lot of people
cannot answer it
thomas aquinas gives a very simple
definition of what the law is the law is
an ordinance of reason for the common
good
made by him who has care of the
community and promulgated that's it very
simple
an ordinance of reason
for the common good of the whole
community law is not just how to benefit
some people at the expense of other
people in the community it's actually
for the common good
made by the person who has charge of the
care of the community the authority who
has care of the community
and then promulgated declared publicly
and followed by all
but that's not how the libs view law
anymore
the way the libs view law is that
there's one set of rules for them and
another set of rules for everyone else
the way the libs view the law is that
the law is a a way
to gain
the advantage for certain interest
groups
and this is not me denigrating the left
this is how they openly speak of the law
that that the law and politics is not a
matter of civilized reasoned debate
where we persuade our fellow citizens of
what is good for all of us the true
common good not just the
amalgamation of all of our individual
interests lumped together but the actual
common good that serves everyone that
leads to a flourishing republic what is
a republic it means the things we all
hold in common
no they don't view it that way they say
well the law is a way for this
marginalized group to finally stick it
to that other marginalized group they
view it as sort of the opposite of a
common good yeah raise those gas prices
that'll stick it to those rube idiot
conservatives who are polluting our
environment and it won't affect me
because i've got my tesla yeah let's
shut down the economy and shut down all
of the stores for
not just months but years at a time
because i've got my laptop lifestyle it
doesn't matter i can just do work in my
nice apartment in new york and oh the
working class the blue collar worker who
can't get his paycheck anymore well too
bad whoopsie daisy that'll show him
maybe he should be a little bit more
like me
right now go to goodranchers.com
knowles k-n-r-w l-e-s for my favorite
meat
one area that we have seen inflation
really spike recently is in the grocery
store i'm sure that you've seen it it
feels like prices have doubled
except while prices have doubled in the
grocery store good ranchers prices have
stayed low and affordable
what's really amazing too so you can
just buy one-off boxes of meat from good
ranchers and i would recommend it you
can get really great stuff try out lots
of different stuff but if you subscribe
which is in my view the better way to do
it you don't even have to think about it
again you just get that wonderful meet
delivered reliably
if you subscribe
your price never goes up so you've got
insane inflation everywhere in the
country and yet your best price for meat
is locked in
for life
eighty-five percent of the grass-fed
beef that you get in the united states
it's not really from
the united states it's imported from
overseas again that low quality stuff
instead get that good high quality
american meat and lock in your price for
life get a 30 discount on top of all
that right now on prime steaks and
better than organic chicken go to
goodranchers.com
knowles to save on the quality you've
been looking for good ranchers takes the
guesswork out of the grocery store by
sourcing everything from local farms and
shipping it to your door use code
knowles canada wlas enjoy your box of
100 american meat 30 in savings on top
of that order now to combat inflation
with good ranchers american meat
delivered
i'm glad that you liked that clip if you
want more clips ring the bell subscribe
get notifications also what i would
strongly recommend is you go to your
podcast app apple podcast spotify stitch
or google play wherever you get your
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show it's very easy click subscribe
if you would be so kind maybe leave a
five star review and we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]